um but he also started on ADHD Medicaid
he doesn't he doesn't like it
I know so that here's well that's why
here's why here's why I forgot about our
encounter because because I meant no I
mentioned it to you in Austin and I said
we had to talk about it and we said we'd
have to talk about it I went oh my God
this is another okay
be him and Tom Cruise
so is it Adderall it's a ritalin oh what
I just worry about it why because it's
an amphetamine yeah it's it has the
potential to stimulate those parts of
the brain that we associate with
addiction now I'm not going to argue
with success you're doing great right
yeah I mean obviously it has yourself
signs off on it he does and I I have an
adverse effect to it almost it's like I
don't when people say speed it doesn't
it makes me I could fall asleep right
now well that's what it does to
stimulant addicts stimulator stimulant
addicts go down on his on stimulants
yeah it's weird typically yeah yeah yeah
but also also so do ADHD and add
patients too yeah yeah makes me call it
like
um
when something has the opposite effect
of something it's like it is
idiosyncratic really it's yeah it is
yeah that's what they call it but but it
is common you know not a lot of addicts
necessarily spin up that's where people
get a little misconceived about you know
I could tell when somebody's on meth you
may not because sometimes so you're
worried that it's gonna trigger I worry
it keeps the biology operating you're
doing all this hard work to stay sober
and part of the staying sober is letting
those parts of your brain just
re-equilibrate and you might be tickling
that part a little bit throughout the
government I'll tell you Doctor I'll
tell you something
um and this has never happened before my
life
and this happens probably once or twice
a week I'll have a conversation with
somebody at a comedy club
and halfway in the conversation they'll
go whoa and I'll go what and they'll go
you're still here
and I go what do you mean it's like
usually this is about the time where you
walk away during a conversation during a
conversation no I know it works and I
want to listen yeah don't get me wrong
it works and it does work for me and if
I wasn't on it I would be
I I don't know about my happiness but I
think I would be hey what are
alternatives yeah what is the
alternative there are some non-stimulant
add medications out there are they just
as effective no they'd be different uh I
don't want to kid them they're not as
effective but sometimes they are even
clonidine you know is one of those you
know intuitive and this stuff it's one
of the medicines they use for this to
try to avoid the stimulant part but look
you're doing great right and you just
keep telling your sponsor what you're
doing and if he sees you start to go
south you'll have somebody there to tell
you but what are the tall tell signs
your thinking it's [__] up I see you
know how that works right yeah yeah I do
this is the problem with addiction is
that it's not
striving or
preoccupying or or craving it's you
start thinking things are good ideas
that get you closer to a relapse
right including hiding from your
response or thing you know these things
that you like I don't want to tell them
about this those are good ideas that's
your brain going that's right that's a
good idea because then then a little
later on we're gonna try something else
and then a little more and now we're all
full in could it give you like a false
sense of confidence in those what about
false sense it could you mean the the
stimulant yeah that can make you
grandiose if it's not working right it
can really go inflate I don't agree
because I I don't see that because since
I've been on it right in the last seven
months or whatever right
um it's driven me into going to meetings
more because I can still feel right that
I I if I don't I'm depressed I'm not I'm
feeling not connected to people and I
it's forced me to go you know what this
is the feeling that you have so when you
go out so I'm gonna do a counter thing
and just keep going to meetings so this
this is why I'm not absolutely dogmatic
about everything right okay
your sister's one flavor and your dad
that this thing that has ethical
problems your dad did this thing but but
it's it's a thing that works for that
kind of addiction
yeah and uh and Bobby has multiple
things going on and if you don't pay
attention to some of them it can also
take you out so maybe he's at a stage
right now we're treating the add or ADHD
it's add right ADHD yeah ADHD and if you
don't treat it properly that's a risk
right so it's it's you got to navigate
gotta navigate as long as he's looking
good doing good being honest being of
service telling the sponsor everything
in pretty good shape today and again
it's one day at a time every one moment
at a time and I also everyone in the
room I want to say
if do you see Behavior right that seems
concerning tell him anything I would
love I've been there no no no no
hello Lieutenant man yeah yeah yeah
listen all right you're Lieutenant yeah
no no no right I'm letting everyone in
this room call me out on it
would you I don't think you do it though
George
I think you're too scared he is really
nice this